[Musique]
ce soir je vais vous parler de quelque
chose
excusez moi d'abord je suis pas très
habituel et parler devant les gens je
suis timide
donc je prends à rêver comprendre vous
étiez déjà arrivé de rêver
vous étudiez arrivé de rêver
voilà je crois que chacun de nous a déjà
raillé à faire le rêve mais c'est là que
je me réparer ce soir c'est passé rêve
qu'ont fait lorsqu'on ordre mais c'est
le rêve d'une rave dont je vais reparler
ses divisions 1,8 un objectif convention
voilà pourquoi ce soir j'aimerais
partager avec quelqu'un
comment réaliser son rêve voilà voilà
tout a commencé je mettrai en avant par
les membres de mon histoire avant de
vous expliquer certaines choses
certaines expériences que j'ai eu à
vivre pandore qui dans mon parcours
tout a commencé en 2000 tous et j'ai
tout donné dans cinq ans je venais juste
avant de finir mes études universitaires
et mon église avion at il une formation
sur le multimédia
si vous ne m'intéressait pas vraiment
mais je me suis dit bon du coup je vais
rien de toute façon comme de son mari
l'a dit j'ai une énième soit japon soit
je gagne je me suis dit par curiosité
j'essaie un peu de vie dans ces pour
participer à la formation
et lorsque je participe à cette
formation des enseignants passez moi
yann excusez-moi j'ai décidé mais j'ai
été vraiment touchée lorsque il y avait
des parties avait la partie cinéma et la
partie photographie et j'étais vraiment
et puis lorsque je voyais qu'à travers
ne font aucune autre formateur exposé
qu'on pouvait les voir des différents
émotions cyril d'autres dont je vais
chercher là et on voit ces photos
j'étais vraiment touché nouveau requis à
travers une image on peut transmettre
des émotions et là on voit des jeunes
les jeunes versions qui sont entrés des
sous et on voit qu'il y en a chois qui
sont entrés d'exprimer l'espoir mais moi
avec cette photo est là sur cette photo
qu'est ce que vous voyez ce que cette
photo la tristesse effectivement et
c'est cette photo
d'autres à venir des rentes et pour
d'autres personnes fait mieux que la
personne et la peur n'est ce pas et
c'est cesser tous et ses photos m'ont
vraiment touché je me suis dit ça va se
renforcer si tu es quelque chose à
manger ou libre je sens que j'ai
vraiment désir d'un jour de devenir un
écrivain de la vie autrement dit un
photographe professionnel
et voilà est la plus grande question que
je me suis posée c'est vrai je désire
devenir un photographe
c'est un rêve que j'avais mais je me
demande quand je vais réaliser ça
pouvait devenir un photographe alors que
j'ai des sans emploi j'avais pas de
moyens pour me procurer un appareil
photo un appareil photo des derniers
cris et je me suis mis à réfléchir à
réfléchir à décines bon commun d'être
toujours permis à chacun d'entre nous de
rêver mais la réalisation c'est des
formes d'échangés bancaires et toujours
cette même année
je rentre un peu voilà enseignements des
jets a décroché mon premier emploi dans
une entreprise qu en place à kinshasa et
j'ai été engagé comme haïti sa pose et
c'est vrai que j'avais un salaire
j'avais j'avais déjà grâce à l'aide mais
l'invitation difficultés que j'avais à
l'époque et que je n'arrivais pas à
épargner suffisamment pour me procurer
un appareil photo parce qu'à l'époque
comme c'est la ville de kinshasa
les parents avaient presque vu d'emplois
il fallait que j'aie j'aide ma famille
pour subvenir à vernaison et surtout que
j'avais deux frères qui est en train de
tirer il un échec le maroc où il ya le
faire atteindre synergie auditifs et
c'est moi et me suffisait pas dé
réaliser mon rêve en 2000 tous trois ans
plus tard ouais je n'utilise jamais
changé
pourtant après j'ai changé j'ai décroché
mon deuxième monde aisément cacher ses
formes et quelques mois plus tard on m'a
vite et ici a lâché et je vous assure
c'est là que je me suis dit qu'est coûte
que coûte je dois réaliser mon rêve est
maintenant que j'ai épargné pendant que
je faisais des efforts et scénarisé
corrèze je me dis que c'est vrai qu'il
ya des appareils qui coûtent 15 moins
cher ce sont des très beaux appareils
jamie dimon
si j'attends que j'ai tout ce moyen pour
avoir ces dangers restent fermement je
me suis dit qu'avec le peu que j'ai que
je commence d'abord avec un petit
appareil est ensuite merci de suite avec
les temps je pourrai me produire et l
appareil dernier et voilà c'était mon
premier appareil au 1er mai
c'est lui qui m'a aidé a commencé à
réaliser mon rêve
et après cela je voudrais vous poser
beaucoup de questions
c'est vrai que j'ai eu à effectuer des
formations en ligne
avoir des conseils mais certaines
monnaies qui étaient tous les domaines
j'ai passé beaucoup d'autres démontent
rennais d'apprendre des fois même j'ai
été entraînée d'emprunter certains
appareils chez une personne pour m'aider
à m'exercer plus avant que je veux que
mon propre appareil et je me suis posé
une question encore je fais du bon c'est
vrai que j'aimerais réaliser
quel nom je dois donner je vais donner à
ses rêves que j'ai de les réaliser alors
ils font quand j'étais jaloux la chine
populaire
j'étais sorti un peu à l'extérieur
j'étais en train d'observer des siennes
et j'ai constaté les choses par rapport
à kinshasa germain qu est le sien de
dopage il est vraiment un ciel
j'espère que vous n'êtes pas supposés du
même avis que moi c'est ainsi un tel
revenu j'ai aussi du bois objets j'aime
beaucoup la nature juridique est un
moment après ils pensaient à traverser
la terre est si riche du boivre
évangéliser si elle photographie ce
combat
sa coque partent quand j'étais un peu de
d'être un tueur de motion ap et je
voyais sky et à ses 18 et j'ai vu lui
aussi doit marcher et je crois que je
crois déjà quelqu'un dans la salle
comprend pourquoi des noms de ma boîte
de mon entreprise pour ténor d'élèves et
photographies et je te rassure notre
génial à voir c'est non j'ai commencé à
faire des séances photo gratuit deux
fois aux couverts du foie
hakim est né tout seul on a mis deux à
prendre en compte davantage avant de
m'élancer dans la vraie vie
avant de vous lancer dans la vie
professionnelle vous savez dans chaque
match avant le match brillant
mon entraînement il faut passer le
moment d'entraînement et enfin que vous
puissiez de lorsque vous serrez sur
terrain où s'est effectuée et gagner
parfois des matches c'est pourquoi j'ai
préféré passer mon temps à me former à
faire des séances photos ça sonnait
ancien mannequin je passais beaucoup de
temps je me forme et je faisais des
recherches avant de me lancer dans la
vie dans la vraie vie et en 2006 voilà
en demi séance vidéo sur ce qu'ils j'ai
été contacté par une personne il m'a dit
dis que je m'entends est ce que tu peux
venir
l'image de mon frère je dis moi pourquoi
pas je sais une occasion et je n'avais
pas vraiment galéré des photos pour
montrer aux clients
mais ce qui m'a vraiment touché c'est
que les clients dit c'est vrai que tu
n'as rien tu n'as jamais encore fait
quelque chose mais je crois je sais que
tu peux dire quelque chose
jamie dimon sikila une personne arrive à
croire c'est toi il faut faire quelque
chose et satisfait et je me suis bâti
ses vins que j'avais vraiment une peur
j'ai cru que c'est pas le mont bachy je
ne connaissais pas des endroits où faire
des photos je ne sais rien je vous
rassure c'est j'étais vraiment en valeur
ces jours là mais avec les forts avec la
persévérance avec l'endurance comme
marcel dadi la persévérance je me suis
dis quelquefois je vais
tu peux le faire et je vous assure sans
me vanter gg c'était ma première
expérience et c'était cela a été une
réussite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelles sont les différentes photos qui
sont réveillés après voir pour terminer
aussi généré partager quelque chose avec
un effet renseigné je vais redire dans
mon cas quelqu'un qui est réalisé son
rêve ne dépend pas de l'âge ne dépend
pas du moyen sans nécessairement mais ça
dépend de la manière dont tu tues tu ça
dépend de chacun d'entre nous de la
persévérante l'endurance et la
détermination que nous avons voilà
pourquoi dire à mon parcours j'aimerais
partager avec quelqu'un ce soir les
différents points que gia expérimenté
dire à montbard le premier boisset il
faut rêver tout grand projet pour les
réaliser il faut vous avez raison
d'avoir une vision un architecte avant
de construire une maison
je crois que avant même d destinés je
vois que tout vient de la tête et pour
réaliser de grandes choses comme j'en ai
dit il faut d'abord avoir la vision il
faut d'abord avoir des visions sans la
vision
je ne sais pas comment tu es ce que vous
avez vous quand tu ne sais pas où tu
dois aller tu risques je n'ai jamais
arrivé voilà pourquoi il est important
d'avoir d'avoir un rêve d'avoir une
vision et lorsque la vision est claire
c'est un nom que nous pouvons maintenant
passer à l'acte il est avancé dans la
bouche bée les partagent aussi la pensée
d wade disney je crois que chacun
d'entre eux de gaudi il a dès ses 6 pour
réaliser un dépôt pour réaliser quelque
chose de grand pour réaliser de grandes
choses il faut réveiller
voilà pour moi j'ai mes règles des
mauvais élèves régulièrement vous devez
avoir d'abord une vision
vous devez avoir une vision et y'a rien
pensez y à réinverser dans la vie mais
qui dit saisi que ce traitement peuples
aient péri faute il faut avoir une
vision et c'est alors qu'on ne peut pas
faire du surplace des erreurs il faut
prendre des risques il est il est vrai
dire à quelqu'un ce soir que lorsque
vous nous aimez les entrepôts quelque
chose de grand à la vie que vous avez à
prendre les grandes décisions par
exemple s'est marié faire des études il
ya deux fois dans notre for intérieur en
forme une forme de bouclier qui vous
critiquent et vous permet de ne pas
penser qui vous permet d il ya des fois
des questionnements qui lui dit qu'est
ce que tu vas arriver ya des moments où
tu sens combien de tout dans mon coeur
tu dis que tu dis que tu sûr
ok c'est vraiment un rêve que tu les
regardes et j'aime bien sûr si vous
laisser toutes ces choses vous envahir
il reste vous risquez de ne jamais être
séparé c'est pourquoi il est important
de prendre les risques et ses risques à
prendre ne se fait pas par un claquement
des doigts ces risques à fond ne serait
pas pas tu te réveilles matin ça demande
beaucoup de doses de travail de
sacrifices de persévérance comme acer
l'a dit ça demande beaucoup d'efforts
des privations des fois même de des
rénos mans aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train de contempler mais si nous
comptons coronado
mais regardez ses hommes pour qu'ils
arrivent d'horizons ce sont des hommes
qui se sont sacrifiés ils se sont privés
de beaucoup de choses qu'ils ont pris
les risques et périls n'ont pas vécu
d'amères jeunesse que nous avons tekki
que nous vivons aujourd'hui certainement
alors 12 ans il n'était pas comme nous
dit-on en train de jouer et il était en
train de faire autre chose
ils se sont privés soit de la mosson et
si vous pouvez des mots creux de choses
et journée nous contemplons ils sont
devenus meilleurs pas ce qu'est un chai
ils ont emprunté et quelqu'un dit qu'il
n'y a pas de leadership sans prendre les
risques il faut apprendre à prendre les
risques et savait pas dire de mettre
notre vie en danger pour les risques ne
veut pas dire que d'émettre la vue
d'autrui en danger n'en prend des
risques et vous avancez grande idée de
nous démarquer de sortir d'une autre
limite notre zone de confort
c'est ça prend des risques passer à
l'action c'est vrai tu as une vision
c'est vrai que tu as un rêve mais il est
où il est il est important de passer à
l'action
il est le moment de passer à l'action et
si vous passez par si vous n'arrivez pas
à prendre des risques
vous risquez légèrement à l'effet à la
révision des fautes et moi ce n'était
pas facile pour moi c'est vrai j'étais
envahi par cette peur est ce que ça va
marcher
les personnes seules ou pas j mais je ne
serais ce que je fais je me suis dit que
ça va marcher même si le moment
l'intérieur mais dit que ça ne marchera
pas mais je crois fermement que ça
marche
troisièmement n'ai pas baissé du mois
les bras pitot n'est pas décidée mois
après est née chez mon frère john il a
dit que tomasz elle vit et d'enzo cet
homme si il avait il avait considéré ces
échecs tous ces essais qui n'avait pas
marché aujourd'hui je pense je le bois
si rien ne m'en étais la seule personne
qui les verrait exemple je pense que
aujourd'hui même dans cette salle aux
fenêtres aux fenêtres avec des noms de
tempête avec des mouches et ça je pense
je ne pense pas ce qu'on a parlé des
interdictions inique n'est ce pas
certainement lui il était unique c'est
la seule personne ici certains qu'ils
devaient réaliser ses rêves
et si cet homme abandonné à cause de
tous ses échecs
aujourd'hui on a des pas avoir cette
lumière
vous n'allez pas voir et cet objet
malgré ces échecs il a pris ses attentes
un moyen un tremplin
6 c'est pourquoi j'aimerais dire à
quelqu'un ne considérait pas vos échecs
mais prenez ces échecs comme un moyen de
vous amener vers les 6 et marcher sur
vous pour vous pour vos échecs et a
précisé que vous c'est en fait un moment
transitoire où vous aider à réussir
c'est qu'il n'est pas fait reconnaît pas
réussir
c'est pourquoi ne laissez pas de bruit
ne baissons pas les bras
même si aujourd'hui ça ne marchait pas
demain ça ne marche pas mais sachez les
uns jouent ça marchera mon en 2012
j'avais besoin j'avais ce désir de
machete un appareil de créer mon ampli
mon entreprise mais ça n'a pas marché
c'est en quatre ans plus tard quelque
chose soit arrivé ici en demies du g10
et qui ment je pense que je ne peux pas
les réaliser je pense qu'aujourd'hui
carrément soyons déterminés je pense que
chacun d'entre nous a dit observer des
formules chacun aura des services les
défauts mais lorsqu'ils sont entrés des
marchés en colonie je crois bien mais et
c'est à vous de prendre une pierre et
mettre devant les fourneaux
qu'est-ce que vous avez remarqué que
vous allez remarquer ils vont contourner
et prétend comme aucun autre objet par
exemple un morceau de bois mais d'abord
des vents qu'est-ce qu'ils allaient
marquer ils vont contourner
il a le même où chacun d'entre eux a
pour réaliser des projets dans votre vie
vous aurez des obstacles vous aurez des
bâtons dans les roues
vous aurez des découragements vous aurez
vos courbes beaucoup d autres centres
financiers s'appelle mourad ça va être
ça va être physique mais s'il vous plaît
lorsque votre vision est claire ekin
obstacle devant de vous faites comme la
fourmi pour tourner là ne vous arrêtez
pas beaucoup de gens sont passés ont
raté les occasions parce qu'ils ont
préféré faire marche arrière
ils ont préféré tourner beaucoup de
personnes sont morts aujourd'hui sont
dans le cimetière parce que ces gens
lorsque l'on vit l'obstacle dévoilé
devant raison du bon apparemment c'est
pas dommage de paris
mais après nous être comme ses fruits
quand ou non tout les obstacles
elle est très fort et peintre et dire
mais considérer ces obstacles comme un
moyen pour vous daniel dubois
pourquoi la fourmi ton tour parce qu'un
fou remis un objectif précis son but est
d'arriver là dans le point b même si tu
mets une barrière humaine obstacle pour
lui qui va contourner et va rentrer pour
arriver dans le bois au poignet et il
allait même pour l'eau si quelqu'un veut
réaliser un rêve le rapport à marcher et
à contourner les obstacles est terminée
[Musique]
soyons patients la patience est la clé
de toutes les portes
n'abandonnons pas c'est vrai que nous
avons besoin dé réaliser des actions
notre notre personne mais il est
important de patienter chaque chose a
son temps
il ya un temps pour aimer et un temps
pour raconter
soyez patients bobo coordination sont
passés outre sont passés à côté de leur
destinée parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
passion je pense que tout est possible à
celui qui ose travail dans ce qui pose
tout d'abord celui qui rêve aux travail
et n'abandonne jamais c'est le discours
des vrais dollars
un jeune réalisateur canadien qui a dit
cela et il croit et moi aussi je fais
cgc de même penser je crois qu'ils aient
tout est possible à celui qui rêve
d'amour qui oserait du pont des risques
qui travaillent et qui n'abandonne
jamais malgré deux s'installent
j'ai dit et je vais
[Applaudissements]